here's the code for the refresh button
in the forecastfragment menu XML file we
wanted to appear in the overflow menu so
we set show as action as never we also
declare the string you can find the
string here in the string set XML file
which is located in the values folder
which is in the Reds folder you can get
your strings that XML file translated
into different languages this adds
additional values folders under res for
example you would have values yes for
Spanish values - fr for French and
within each of those values folders you
would have a strings at XML file which
would contain the localized strings for
that language since translation does
cost money as a pro tip you can March
strings that you don't need translated
using translatable equals false for
example if it's a proper name or if it's
for debugging like this one then you can
indicate to the translator that they can
skip over these strings